hey 7 i'm excited to try some new
cookies now there's a story here I've
got a box of cookies and how this
happened this came from one of my
facebook fans named Andre Andre Rodin to
say hey I'm gonna him across your
YouTube channel when I needed some
mindset motivation I watched quite a few
of your videos after that I run my own
bakery we just set up due to lack of
quality cookies in the current market
and I wanted to change that to show what
real cookies should be like after being
this is 10 months I won top award the
bigger can win in New Zealand I've
entered twice after that and I place in
the top three every year I had make all
my products and I'm nearing a huge
milestone of 500,000 handmade cookies by
the end of this year just thought I'd
get in touch as you push that on all of
your videos checking out when you have a
minute on your kitchen code and said I'm
a believer rock on okay so i'll go back
dontre said Andre is awesome 70 some of
your cookies and he said yeah so he sent
me this box I I went to so the scheme
that my condo and they said you have an
order and it took a while to come to New
Zealand didn't know what it was and I
got this box and I puts this box who
sending me something here and then on
the label and you guys read it it says
cookies so I got really excited and so
there's a bunch of cookies in here and I
thought what I do is open up different
parks with different people and see how
we enjoy the experience so hopefully
these cookies are as good as Andre says
so neat is the first guinea pig let's
open it up and see we've got chocolate
chip cookies oh look at this check this
out Andre put his face on the packaging
this is looking good and it says
finalist 2013 New Zealand food awards
I'm excited okay
[ __ ] chip that's our standard right
Papa Jeff and Zac cookies peanut
brownies brownies ginger cookies i'm not
a big ginger pan so long after five and
OH garlic crostini oh and i know it
buried at the bottom hi Evan I'm sure
you will enjoy these treats happy face
Andre and there's the man Andre okay
which one we're gonna track you just
having a hard time making up her mind ok
let's try Enza we've never done enza oh
it smells good ingredients butter is
number one ingredient golden syrup
baking soda sugar bowl oats coconut
coconut coconut ok ok busy [ __ ] [ __ ]
right cheers ready I've been starving
and I was gonna do something but then we
will make way to make this video ok but
we can't eat before I having a cookie ok
oh go on all that needs growth I like
this look at this on the back it says
thank you for buying my product I hand
roll every cookie in this bag you are
holding I love that leave a comment the
cookies go with team I'm saying milk if
we had no
you don't you you're going to dip it in
I want to dip this in this alone I'm
Zach anzac cookies goes with no okay
it's the next day and I've got the kids
over Hayden's here and Nina's nephew and
niece are with us too last night was
awesome eating the cookies you can see
that I totally finished the bag and I'm
gonna go surprise them and we're gonna
do which one on the top chip which
chocolate chip chocolate chip cookies
and we'll Surprise them ok let's see
that and see the reaction see if they
like this one ok it's surprise time ok I
need everybody together ok stand there
okay we got Hayden and Stephanie and
Jeffrey everybody wave hi we are gonna
try a special brand new yummy bag of
chocolate chip cookies who wants one who
wants one ok let's open this up ok when
Peggy gentle oh can I smell oh they
smell amazing oh my god I'm gonna eat
all this bag again ok one each don't eat
yet just hold it Jeffrey comfy
okay I'm three we can all eat together
I'm gonna take 12 doesn't have one two
ready cheers cheers Cheers one two three
hey pretty good huh you know who visits
to me an entrepreneur named Andre he
sent it from New Zealand okay i'm over
at my parents place we are celebrating
my sister's birthday Stephanie yay
Stephanie what words of wisdom do you
have for people Stephanie that's your
word of it Stephanie's going to New York
tomorrow morning she works got a new job
so we are here to try some cookies ooh
ok second you get the pic mean the
birthday girl we have a ginger and
peanut brownies peanut brownies okay
we'll let you do the honors opening up
the cookie bag Thank You Andre this one
yes okay Cheers
cheers mr. Wu stretch there you go okay
they're yummy but I don't know where
they come from this a brownie yeah stop
and chewy look around but they're good
okay bringing a little bit of New
Zealand to try them Thank You Andre okay
Jason is here and we are going to open
up another bag of cookies and see how
they taste so there's one bag left we
got the ginger cookies they should be in
there now I've been avoiding this bag
cuz i'm not a big ginger fan wait a
minute so this is like hold on i think
there's pieces of ginger like you see
i'll click the show Oh amazing pieces of
ginger I'm on it so it's kind of
freaking me out so bad so open it up and
let's all natural ingredients how it is
there you go zeeland me I wasn't sure it
is we're debating whether this was
organic or not so and it's pretty easy
like Christmas just like on Christmas i
could never open the presents so sad
poor jason i'm jeannie that somebody
gets his teddy ruxpin and they came in
opening I don't time I ok let me have
one here too will do a choice you like
no I excel to try it alright so there's
two big pieces of ginger maybe I can
avoid those and cheers Cheers
oh the cook is amazing I'm about the
ginger part have you gotten I did you
eat the ginger no I'm getting that
they're fresh I'm so tasty man this is
one of the hmm okay I'm gonna eat the
ginger bit see what happened not in your
sushi you go for sushi I don't you
ginger you know what ginger is not bad
uh I would eat this this is the first
ginger that I have in mind you I'm on
during I'm a new man I'm honored props
200 this isn't bad you introduce you to
a new yeah I like it even the ginger
things that you suck on when you have a
NOSSA when you're nauseous mm-hmm night
I can't have those cuz of the ginger
Martin Luther go mmm handy ginger always
rise I was right good all right thanks
I'm dry one more box left we're down to
our last bag of treats from andres
kitchen this is a cookies and it's been
sitting there for a while every day Nina
comes home was either going to try these
things we're going to try to map these
are garlic crostini garlic crostini the
hammer smell you know what's up the
camera smell for all you people at home
mmm breathe in that garlic yum in area
okay ready go cheers just look it
okay we're going to finish this off so
thank you andre going to visit andre's
kitchen learn more about these awesome
parks believe